aber damals lud freunde ich darf ich
heute recht herzlich willkommen heißt in
seiner neuen nicht lachen challenge
zusammen mit sandra
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da habe ich haben uns in jeder
leitungswasser vorbereitet was wir
gleich in den mund nehmen werden haben
die befindet sich hinter der kamera wie
geht's dir heute an diesem wunderschönen
eckigen tag wo es nur regnet es ist ihr
reich auch zu messer
weiß mit euch
tillich hat auf jeden fall einige witze
vorbereitet die sie uns vielleicht
vorlesen wird sei noch nicht am leitung
fast am morgen wenn wir lachen
froh ist
wenn wir nachher mit hat auf jeden fall
sei dass man die andere person halt das
spuckt keine ahnung das ist auf jeden
fall der sind das video gesehen auch
schon den beide haben virgin da ist
alles dem minister zum de
ich habe einmal diesen geilen welches
wetter an mit dem smiley globus fordert
auch google wäre für den verein braucht
selby stellen wir deine culliford nicht
gezogen ihn anzuziehen hier steht karl
sieht aus wie schmutz und ja ich kaufe
nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
den nutzt
[Musik]
sein wird vorbereiten augen zu machen
weil da muss man gar nicht sehen
[Musik]
roddick seite ist gut für die gesundheit
ich habe darunter gmbh alle
ich würde
das bisschen not rico augen zu dies sei
es nicht gut für die gesundheit sind zu
dick ich glaube und liebe eine zweite
meinung dr die sind festlich
vater zum sowie 1 6 in deutschland doch
irgendwie du
wieder von den listen
ich muss kunstrasen geht also doch ich
muss richtig daten gerade
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einmal 14 gemeinsam ebenfalls runter
fast das wichtigste mal im schweizer st
es ist das reh
schweißausbruch oder durch schweiß aus
untergetaucht ist
ein
alter bekannter
war das ist so ekelhaft locations dir
nicht so ekelhaft und ich war einfach
schon du schon heute erst übermorgen es
tut mir leid von herbst an die ich
lieben und denken sich die sehr gut
gesichert am nächsten tag berichten
eröffnete riesen halten uns ein kleiner
junge welcher er denkt dass sich alle
egal wie niedrig am nächsten tag in der
zeitung verrückter hinterlässt
verwüstung in sachen bank
welches gemüse mal die besten witze
leute ich hab keine maßnahme
derzeit haben jetzt wasser auffüllen
kann ich mich immer kurz designprodukte
hier forscherin freude es gibt keinen
neuen schwarzen studien mit einem
doppelten zweiten design es gibt diesen
blauen twitter mein absolutes lieblings
produkt diesel weißen es gibt ein neues
pop shop jetzt gibt es zwei neue tasten
es gibt die stadt es gibt dort sogar
griff
es ist so wie kraft hier ja
ich weiß nicht wie oft ist
sie ein typisches verhalten ist
schrecklich ich verlasse dich er sonst
nicht geben sie warum er der bundesrat
haben können ihnen zu rechnen weil sie
sich den ganzen tag so beschäftigen
was macht eine wolke mit jung kreis die
zum wolkenkratzer
ist schamlos wie es manche verfällt wenn
er sonst nicht ändern fährt
[Musik]
denn ein tropfen auf mein iphone 12
kommt der kosten live 13 was sagt man
sind sich zwei nasen verdienen da läuft
was
was ein katalanischer urknall album
wer ist jung und blickt neben den
anderen badegästen drängt wird es mehr
eine mehr user
ein sport wird berühmte nicht sofort ein
spanier ist alles schwere zu mir
und zwei deutsche bank ein radio mit 200
japanern auf und gefastet haben versucht
das geld zu versteuern
schade ich hätte ja echt nicht gedacht
ist unser sohn ist mal so weit schaffen
stimmt das katapult ist wirklich
krank und der wollte es unter den armen
verteilen
doch bei den armen
unter
wasser hält man von kennenlernen
bebengebiet milchshakes
die zuschauer die andere nicht aus
dieses wetter ist so neues
ich hab doch google eben alles
so was ich dir lukas mio chf
was noch wichtig
[Musik]
also leute dieses video genauso
beschissen fandet wie ich dann
sagte dass wir das nie wieder tun wir
haben so was ähnliches vor zwei jahren
oder so schon mal aufgenommen das haben
wir uns damals schon gesagt wir machen
das nie wieder weil es sofort losgehen
aber jetzt aber jetzt noch mal gemacht
also wenn euch diese nicht lachen
challenge gefallen hat mit haben die
spitzen dann lasst gerne einen daumen
unter dem video ab und man kann halt und
klickt auf die glocke über die weitere
videos nicht verpassen wollen sie das
merchandising darum der rudi oder dieses
wetter sind die erst seit heute dem
lokal shopping.de zu haben also schaut
auch gern mal lukas shop.de vorbei und
sagen hat die letzten sechs worte ich
hasse dich für ein ganzes leben lang
es waren halt keiner sechs worte ich
hasse dich für mein ganzes leben lang
acht
trupps unter kritik